in the textbook to get to this to get
the results for the derivatives of sine
cos and tan and all the reciprocal
functions oh there's all this theory
fluff that starts off with nothing to do
with calculus why are you talking about
this why are you talking about circles
why don't you let inequalities why are
you doing that
Celina tan X and how they're related to
each other that's just way too confusing
and then after like two hours of reading
you get to this graph and all of the
pieces they've been working on for sort
of like it's you know we've been working
on the this payoff for the season finale
for like 20 episodes and now all the
pieces come together you're like oh
that's why the TARDIS exploded or
whatever it is okay so they do that so
you get this off of it so that
everything else is in place before he's
making sense okay I think that's really
annoying I don't like that they do it
that way
because you're like I came here I turned
up and I wanted to do this and you're
wasting my time with all this
unnecessary fluff just tell me how to do
it okay
they're part of that desired by is
unreasonable but any pot is reasonable
like it really does take a long time to
milk so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
just gonna start with this spice
straightaway okay now in order to get
the results for this we'll be able to
see it it's sort of visual way but I
won't be able to prove it rigorously
unless I take a few steps back and look
at all that theory stuff so we're gonna
go from here see what we can work out
get some results down and then we'll do
all the necessary proof so that list
you're motivated you're like why I'm
approving the stuff it's like well so
that you can actually say the things we
concluded like visually intuitively that
you really aren't sure okay so here's
why Crusaders and I want to go know what
its gradient function is like how it
behaves but I've only drawn not a
two-pilot can anyone tell me why I only
need to draw from naught to 2 pi because
this graph is periodic we've been doing
this to death recently haven't with
right so if I can tell you about the
gradient function of this
I can tell you about the gradient
function for the entire graph because
it's just repeating over and over again
so the first thing I'm gonna say is sign
right is periodic so it's derivative is
periodic okay now that's a really
helpful it might seem like obvious sort
of thing to start with especially for
those who know the result already but it
sort of is really great for us because
it narrows things down a lot when you're
thinking about what could this possibly
be what is the derivative okay
now let's have a look at this graph and
see what we can deduce about the view
just by looking at just by looking at it
you actually know a whole bunch of
things especially by graphing this thing
about how it behaves okay so for
instance for these two of the spots that
I've drawn over you from nought to 2 pi
you can tell me without any shadow of a
doubt the complete accuracy what the
gradient is there are two very important
spots on you get over there are no
stationary points right so you've got
one here and one here okay now one
stationary point school stationary
points stationary with a stationary min
hey what's that about
it's what's the words they should be
mean would you say an object is
stationary you me just don't really get
still it isn't going anywhere okay
so what they do is they're picturing
this graph as describing the motion of
an object okay and these points in the
graph that object isn't moving right for
infinite time okay
so therefore what can I say about the
derivative the gradient at those
particular points it should be zero
by the way what are the values for X at
those locations fully especially with
aisle two and good we're getting there
radians it's time to see you okay now
let's keep going what else do we know
about on this graph okay well hopefully
when you first learn about doing brain
functions you often might have get given
graph might be like this might be like a
polynomial so like that and then say now
draw for me you don't know what the
equation is but you know it looks like
draw for me it's great you okay you do
something like this you'd say look at
this powder go from naught to / - okay
what can you tell you that the gradient
just gave that follow that positive
because the graph is increasing so I'm
going to put plus signs all the way
across here okay I'm trying to say to
make its myself the gradient is positive
dislocations yeah I can make the same
argument I can say all the way from pile
to the stationary point to the next
stationary point it's going to be
negative it's a decreasing function you
get this okay I should have mentioned as
well we already said at those stationary
points that means just by the positive
nor negative it's zero right and if my
last little section there for three
point two till the end of what I drew
it's positive again okay
now that tells us where the gradient
function is going to be with regard to
the x axis it means from north depart to
do this little domain here the gradient
should be above the x axis in the middle
it should be below the x axis and so on
you get the idea so it's periodic right
and it's alternating up and down we're
sorry
up and down and up and down okay now
what kind of up and what kind of down
where's the where would you say is the
steepest point of the graph you could
make a few different lectures it'll be
they don't want to give a suggestion at
zero it looks pretty steep right and as
you progressed you're not a pilot to
because you're going from positive to
zero you're thinking okay
the gradient is positive but then it's
decreasing it and eventually it hits
zero okay so it's steepest here its
steepest there right there were other
places we said that it's steep as well
what other places on it at one axis and
of course by extension at all right now
I said it's steepest a favor we have
more specific language for describing
news okay I could say it's not just
steepest but at those points there's a
change in concavity that's actually
what's thickness statement is a
concavity are two connected ideas right
so being that you can see look I'm
concave down and then I'm concave up
where I change crude cavities where
those points of steepness and now we
have a special may for those points what
are the colonists it puts inflection of
him now tell me hold on a second when
you have a point of inflection not
always but usually what does that tell
you about the gradient what does it tell
you about the gradient function if the
if I've got I've got this and I'm really
trying to work out this but I've worked
out something about this okay
because points inflection about this guy
right when you have points of inflection
what does that tell you about how tricky
isn't it cuz you wanna be like what am i
describing when this has stationary
points this is zero right but when this
has stationary points this is here which
is the point infection that we're
talking about right so therefore at
these three spots when I draw my
gradient function however it looks right
the grave function should have
stationary points okay if should have
stationary points at the stars that I
draw okay that I've got three okay I
think we have enough patience what would
look like what would this um what would
this look like we said that we've got a
stationary point lining up with this
okay now at the moment because I haven't
give you any scale or that kind of thing
you sort of have to get guests but later
on we're gonna explain this is why you
need all this theory stuff why this
stationary point doesn't just happen
anywhere it happens right here at one
okay y equals one okay so there's my
stationery posters where I've drawn a
pose on top what does it do after that
what we said it's got to be positive but
it's got to come down to zero positive
would come down to zero okay so it's
going to cut through like that okay and
there's my stationary point because my
gradient function the thing I draw now
is zero right okay now even between here
right what's going on the gradient
function is negative that's what all of
my name your signs be right and I've got
to have it's not a turn around lining up
with this point of reflection that I
might do so in between PI over two or
three points to I'm doing this it's
negative its negative its negative
there's my point of inflection turning
point moving but it's going to come back
up to zero right so it turns around in
the area now what's happening here
what's here is kind of the reverse of
what's happening here you see this this
is positive but it's going towards zero
this is positive it's going away with
zero I'm trying to describe the great
you hear the whole time right so I'm
going to be above the axis but I'm
moving toward a stationary point
okay down I should have brought another
color with me but it ran out so let me
just make it really thick and awful as a
graph buts that way you can at least
tell them it's a different thing this
graph I've just draw it in I'm
suggesting is the derivative of sine
okay it matches all of the features that
we've just described okay that you
started over here you've got a
stationary point for the gradient rest
like this put inflection and yeah and
yeah it's positive what I need to be
negative when I need to be positive
again and here are the zeros
corresponding to the station if it's on
the original row and of course as you
know this thing will keep copied because
it's periodic
just like cited okay so now you can tell
me because you know very well what this
graph is what does the derivative the
sine look like it looks like her so it
sure looks like cosine all right so
let's just see if we can play with that
for the rock because once you have this
you actually get every other trig
function and all this to reduce funding
along with it which is kind of nice
right they all come from here because
they all come from science for instance
let's think about cause if I know the
good news of sine is what's the dude if
a cause well I want to try it you guys
know if mass is so much about getting
problems you don't go in terms of
problems you do know right and trying to
mess around them that way now this is a
trig function the only other trig
function that we know the ribbon bar is
so so what can I do to this to twist and
turn it so to look like sine
what's the definition of cause we talked
about this last this is that the comb
stands for complementary right
so yeah den we usually say is you know
because X is equal to sine of now what
you sticking down to make the compliment
how do you get the compliment like if I
had say PI on three he you'd expect PI
on six here but what's the relationship
between those two numbers the other
together you get pilot to so this is
what I should have here is X you care
with that and of course you can flip
around if you want so I'm gonna
substitute that in here instead of cause
I like that better cause binder how to
differentiate side at least I think I do
right let's see if it worked out how
would you go about this so kind of got
two options don't you you could use a
trick expansion you could you could
expand it cuz you know how to do sine a
minus B right but you'll end up with a
problem you know what you'll end up with
another car issue which puts you back in
the same boat she like okay and that's
not a great way to go
but there's another tool in your
different radiating toolbox that you
know that you can use to deal with this
right which doesn't introduce another
cause in what can we do in this you
could substitute something you can
couldn't you another thing is you could
use chain rule
could you this is a function of a
function that inside function is quite a
few minutes X right so can we do this do
this what's the derivative of the inside
if I said the inside functions party
let's act once agree on the inside it's
just negative why isn't it thank you
good done the inside that was hot see we
knew the outside will it be any easier
the outside function is sorry I just
suggested I propose that the derivative
of sine is caught so what will return it
to just because on but don't forget it's
the inside
hi-oh - okay with that but wait a second
remember I just said we could use this
identity but you can say it around the
other way
right you could just as equally say sign
is cause of pylon 2 - X those two
anchors with each other exactly the same
way they're both coordinates right so
therefore here I can get rid of my
clothes again
and I get that hold on stop for a second
I'm suggesting the grain of sign looks
like cosine but having gone through this
this is telling us that if that's true
then the gradient of cosine is negative
sine that's confusing is it but is it
true well let's not look let's try and
do the same thing we did for sine but do
it very quickly for cosine because I
think we've sort of got the idea right
from zero to this stationary point which
is at PI right what's the sign of the
gradient what's the sign of the gravy
from here to here it's negative because
it's a decreasing function right so
that's why your grade is down here okay
for the decreasing I can use the
opposite I didn't say well this parts a
positive so it should be doing this and
sure enough that looks a heck of a one
like leave your side okay
so this looks like it worked out okay
there's one more basic trig function
that we know
now solar mommy way spin like what is
the definition of tip it's sign in a
cause see you like Oh gross quotient
rule really relax not that bad
this is you this is B okay help me out
what do I do
so what is the question
so you - you told me is cause right u -
V okay I could do that
right what's in between - be careful
so you just told me you - please so I
suppose we should do V - you me down
what do we just say negative sign
what's your sides me - you okay one more
cycle at the end all over wake up v
square which in this case is is okay
what am I getting
I've got cos squared plus sine squared
which is okay
today you go these three results because
and ten which of course are built for
Thought sign